A long time ago in a lab far, far away....
Welcome to Science Wars
Chemistry, Bio, Physics and Mathematical!
Which field is best?
(PHYSICS)
I understand the force and energy
Quantum mechanics and relativity
My field is pure and they rely on me
I see the universe like nobody
You may have made fun of me in high school
For being awkward and following the rules.
Now I've got lazers. (Wow, that's really cool!)
May the mass times acceleration be with you...
ATOMS!
ENTROPY!
DARK MATTER!
STRING THEORY!
(CHEMISTRY)
If you want to feel a bond
Then I can give a you a reaction
The element that make up me are the essence
Are my satisfaction
All the other fields out there are so basic
Yeah, I’m the central science
Keep your eye on me, I’ll get you charged
If you need me, call me up on Avogadro's Number
If you leave me, take a titrant
Shove it up your acid buffer
Dopamine and serotonin will keep you good and happy
So get your flask and your glass all set up
And begin to understand the world!
(BIOLOGY)
Within me you’ll find life’s beauty
From genetics to ecology
Symbiosis and not division
Unless it’s mitosis or the study of fission
Even if you don’t pass, at least you’ll enjoy my class!
Evolution has brung us along
All species singing one song
(MATH)
If you want to learn about the world I must say
I am the purest field of study you can take
Immune to misinterpretation
The blueprint of creation
The backbone of all things science
No bias, just constant augmentation
In your mind and observation
No gadgets, just your logic and your time
(PHYSICS) And Pi!
(ALL) Together we will find the answers to life!
With physics - bio - chemistry -
and math
We can SCIENCE